في جازان جنوب غرب السعوديه تتواصل
والاعمال الانشائيه في مطار الملك عبد
الله الدوليه الجديد حيث قربت نسبه
الانجاز في المشروع 45% من المقرر ايضا ان
يستوعب المطار الذي تبلغ مساحته نحو 50
مليون متر مربع نحو ثلاثه ملايين و600 الف
مسافر سنويا كما سيقلقوا فرصا استثماريه
بالاضافه لتحسين البنيه التحتيه لهذه
المنطقه كونه يتوسط مدينه جازان
الاقتصاديه
من مشروع مطار الملك عبد الله بجازان
مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم اسامه مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض تتواجد الان في هذا مشروع مشروع
المطار الجديد في جازان نسبه الانجاز وصلت
الى 45% لكن على الارض التي
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
المشاهدين الكرام لقناه العربيه بالتاكيد
اليوم اقف الان بالضبط على كوبري المغادره
التي يؤدي الى مطار جازان الدولي الجديد
الذي تم ان يعني الانتهاء من الاعمال
الانشائيه بالنسبه بنسبه 43% بالتمام هذه
النسبه بالتاكيد خلال عامين مضت بنسبه
كبيره جدا عدد من المشاريع عدد من المباني
كما تشاهدون الان ثم انشائها بالكامل على
مستوى البناء يستوعب المطار اكثر من ثلاثه
مليون و600 الف مسافر سنويا وهو ما يعتبر
ضعف العدد الموجود في المطار الحالي
المطار ايضا اكثر من
3,500 موقف للمركبات هذا المطار ايضا
يحتوي على عدد من المقرات وايضا عدد من
الاماكن التي تقدم خدمه كبيره جدا
للمسافرين هذا المشروع ايضا وهذه نقطه
مميزه الفريق الانشائي والاداري هو فريق
سعودي بالكامل قام بانشاء هذا للمطار
ومتوقعات كبيره جدا بان خلال اعوام القادم
حول العالم سنتين القادمه ستم همم افتتاح
المطار في حلتها الجديده للحديث اكثر عن
مطار جازان الدولي الجديد سعود ان يكون
معي الدكتور سالم شعيب وهو مدير مشروع
جازان الدولي الجديده اهلا وسهلا فيك
دكتور ابتداء ما نعرف نشره الرابعه حدثنا
اليوم عن ما هي الاعمال الانشائيه التي تم
الانتهاء منها اليوم في مطار جازان الجديد
مساء الخير عليكم اسامه وعلى المشاهدين
الكرام همم يعتبر المطار واحد من اهم
المشاريع الاستراتيجيه في تطوير قطاع
النقل الجوي كذلك المطار يعتبر واحد من
اهم المشاريع الاستراتيجيه في منطقه جازان
راعينا في تصميم المطار احدث الانظمه وهمم
التصاميم في مجال انشاء المطارات الدوليه
المطار انعكاس عكسنا بالتاكيد همم واقع
المنطقه التراثي والعمراني على التصاميم
الداخليه
والخارجيه للمطار نتوقع ان
يسهل المطار سفر ما يقارب
3,600,000 مسافر سنويا المطار يتكون من
تقريبا 39 مبنى لعل اهم مبنى في المطار هو
مبنى صاله السفر الرئيسيه واللي تحتوي على
12 بوابه للسفر عشر بوابات منها متحركه
تستطيع استيعاب 12 طائره في نفس التوقيت
بالاضافه الى ذلك همم برج المراقبه الجويه
بارتفاع 35 متر واللي تم الانتهاء من
تقريبا 76% من اعمال الخرسانه في البرج
ايضا احنا نتكلم اليوم على مدرج طائرات
رئيسي بطول 3,600 متر وعرض 60 متر كذلك
مدرج موازي لا ننسى الصاله الملكيه
بمساحه قدر ب 2,800 متر مربع تم الانتهاء
من تقريبا 40% من جميع اعمال الصاله
الملكيه بالاضافه الى 36 مبنى خدمات راح
تساهم في تشغيل المطار حال افتتاحه بحول
الله احنا المطار مربي انتهينا ولله الحمد
من المرحله الاولى من المطار واللي هي طيب
دكتور اليوم اريد ايضا ان اعرف الارقام
الموجوده اليوم هنا على المستوى الخرسانه
على مستوى ايضا البنا على مستوى التربه
ايضا انتم همم حفرتم امطار في الارض ايضا
ارتفاع ايضا مستوى المطار اليوم على مستوى
البحر حيث ان البحر ايضا قريب منه بقرابه
الثلاثه كيلو مترات تحدثنا عن هذه الارقام
دكتور بشكل موجز زي ما تعرف اسامه احنا
اليوم نقف في ارضيه همم تربه فيها ضعيفه
جدا احنا زرعنا لتدعيم ارضيه المطار ما
يقارب من
350,000 عمود همم حجري كذلك زرعنا ما
2800د خرساني بعمق 32 متر لحمل المباني
الرئيسيه للمطار اليوم احنا نقف على كوبري
المغادره وكذلك احنا انتهينا منه بنسبه اا
95% الدكتور سالم وانت مدير مشروع المطار
الجديد شكرا لك اذا اتحدث اليوم نايف من
هنا من هذا المطار مطار جازان الدولي
الجديد الذي يعتبر بالتاكيد بوابه كبيره
جدا الاستثمار للسياحه نضل لتوجه السعوديه
ايضا الاهتمام بالسياحه وايضا التجاره
خصوصا الاتفاقيه الصينيه الاخيره بما ان
ايضا الميناء الجديد ليس ببعد ذلك البعد
الكبير عن مطار جازان شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
راس العربيه من انجازات